a poder sentarse tranquilamente y
charlar no es acaso un verdadero lujo
con motivo de la decimoctava edición de
la semana de la moda de dakar nos
pareció tan importante como oportuno
darle la palabra a la mujer y desde hace
ya varias décadas no ha dejado de
promover la moda africana en toda su
diversidad a través de sus colecciones o
de sus black fashion week que organiza
en parís fraga montreal o salvador de
bahía en 2014 la diseñadora y mujer de
negocios de 44 años
adama ndiaye fue calificada como una de
las 10 personas más influyentes de
áfrica por efe y 2015 está más bien
hinchas a la capital de la república
democrática del congo diplomacia para
porque mi papá era diplomático allá
como se hacía en la época de momentos
como tengo una hermana gemela
esto lo ideal es jhon nava en los
gemelos tenía una personación miguel
cabrejos
cada vez que alguien cercano al gobierno
tener gemelos y lo que le iba a
visitarlos y entonces fue al hospital a
vernos a mí a mi hermana a mi mamá
porque tuvo un parto muy duro y muy
largo no vino a darnos ofrendas porque
aparentemente eso era lo suyo
y cómo fue la adolescencia
estuve por todas partes un poco
ecléctica y estuve algún tiempo en
alemania y en dakar también por eso
estoy muy porque nunca he pasado un año
así que la adolescencia estuvo llena de
viajes pero mi mamá dice que era
problemática pero no le creo en eso
y los estudios análisis nuestro día moda
para nada estudia ciencias y economía
con la especialización en banca así que
soy una banquera reciclando o incluso up
cycle cycle pero tenía un trato con mi
papá era que después de mis estudios
podría hacer lo que quisieras tomé
cursos de costura y después de eso de
fabricación de modelos
luego hice una pasantía con una libanesa
en santiago en su taller y gracias a
ella aprendí de dónde vienen esas ganas
de trabajar en el mundo de la moda
creo que se remonta a una época en la
que fui y si no recuerdo mal
creo que fue con mi mamá a ver el
desfile nissan
creo que tenía nueve años y quiero ser
como él quiero hacer cosas hermosas como
siempre quise hacer a alguien que
hiciera magia favoritas en sant lo han
expuesto me sentaba esa
multiculturalidad francesa le gustaban
las personas negras de todos los colores
le gustaba todo el mundo y hacía ver
bien a todo el mundo y realmente fue eso
es cierto que mostrar mujeres negras
fotografiar márgenes negras y que era
considerado revolucionario completamente
eso muestra el compromiso de los
artistas porque los veo como artistas no
como personas que solamente hacen
necesario te cuesta la idea que provocó
a las black fashion week y las semanas
de la moda de dakar y si te vamos tú
rubén completamente y realmente siempre
fue una voluntad muy política
dicen que mi componente político pero
acaso no todo compromiso es político eso
siempre podemos hacer las cosas de una
manera personal privada de una manera
que pueda encajar esa gestión
lo que quiero decir es que cada uno de
nosotros tiene sus propios caminos
opcionalmente lo creo que ya es tal vez
mi mentalidad de estado meses cambiar
que cada uno puede dar algo similar a
miradas de personas en el agente fue de
su grano de arena
la pandemia ha combinado muchas cosas ha
sido una fuerza aceleradora o ha sido lo
contrario creo que las cosas en todos
los sentidos así como una voz nadie se
esperaba no volver a ver un desfile del
modeso no volverá a vestirse ante la
masa abrazarse eso es amor
entonces vamos a cambiar esta necesidad
vamos a transformar la vamos a hacer que
ahora se ha divertido sentarse en el
sofá y ver un desfile de ex amiga eso va
a hacernos falta ya nos hace falta
nos hace falta ver a la gente porque
cada show era un aumento festivo éramos
como una familia y muchos abrazos muchos
vinculados y eso tenía su encanto está
de eso claro que me hace falta incluso
si vas capital los fashion films siempre
ha sido una herramienta que tenemos que
incorporar en un tal suerte anoche
es un mensaje para la gente de hoy creo
que lo que realmente nos caracteriza a
mí ya mi equipo es la resiliencia
estelar para cada problema hay una
solución hablo estoy convencida de ellos
entonces sea muy difícil para los
jóvenes que llegan a este mundo el
mensaje es que hay que tener paciencia
la paciencia es la clave de la que y
creo que estamos en una era en la que ya
no sólo se puede hacer artista o
diseñador se tiene que ser el jefe no
sólo el diseñador
ojalá pudiera hacerlo pero
desafortunadamente no puedo porque la
parte más difícil no es necesariamente
hacer colecciones al menos no en esta
parte del mundo sean de colección que
sólo tocan en 12 partidos
[Música]
a dama lucha actualmente por revivir la
industria textil en senegal para cambiar
la imagen de áfrica para sí misma y para
occidente una tarea tan grande como el
mundo mismo
[Música]